and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less why do you
guys such grin on your face right now we
are just two best friends we meet again
howdy everyone my name is my name is
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist and I'm Joshua fields I'm
over and by the way today we're gonna
talk about our favorite things Ryan what
are your favorite things was so the
reason that I was inspired to talk about
this is when we didn't have a guest
today which you've had a ton of guests
lately they've been really exciting it's
challenging to me but I'll tell you my
favorite podcast personally like the
ones to record are the ones where it's
just me and you I totally agree because
we are a couple of silly geese we are
the most interesting people I know so
there's this game that
ll-like supply in our house yeah and
it's guess my favorite things hmm and we
were playing this game and we will go
around a room and like or around the
house of a different room and we just
like sort of alright now it's my turn to
guess Ella's favorite thing and so she
would go look around the house she'd
pick one of her favorite things and it's
always the most silly thing that she has
to pet rocks I almost ended up always
being her favorite thing that's great no
matter what toys or bed or bedsheets we
get for her she has nice pillows and she
has dishes and food and and she has you
know the bins of toys and the games and
the books and the clothes and the
dresses and she picks the pet rocks she
wants rocks man
it's quite the metaphor if I could get
into the pet rocks when I was a kid I
was more into things like Nintendo and
eating cheese and mayonnaise sandwiches
yeah I didn't let food be her her
favorite things but it would be
definitely she would be on that list for
her and and her mother as well wait did
you say you wouldn't let it be one of
her favorite things like in terms of
like my favorite thing is cheese no it's
not
wrong answer Ella yeah you favorite
things broccoli eat this do you remember
I had this nightmare we were in the
middle this is 2014 a middle of a book
tour for this book where's everything
that remains and I never heard of it I
realize
so in I'm looking at the cover if you're
watching this on YouTube yes this is
everything that remains but it's like
staggered Dave did a great job designing
the cover yes Adam took that picture
right this is an atom picture yeah yeah
and the the cover itself is one of the
words gets cut off while I'm I dream we
were 50 cities into our tour just like
we were in the tour and I realized that
everything was spelled wrong on the
cover and it was everything who is
everything that remains every time I
edited it's every tank you kept changing
it well the funny thing is like you know
how anxious I oh I'm having anxiety
about this in my dream something didn't
even happen
and in the dream because you're the
voice of reason when it comes to stress
you might dream like oh it's okay man
we'll just do the tour stops would you
make an accent and like in my dream for
some reason that was a perfectly viable
solution I'm like okay oh my god I don't
know why but that just seems racism and
it seems really strange like like well I
guess in order to correct this mistake
we'll just affect some sort of accent oh
dude anyway we're gonna talk one to her
I was indeed we're gonna talk about some
of our favorite things today I've got a
list actually before we answer our first
question here I've got a list of my 33
favorite things I made this list this
morning I'm gonna read the first five or
six right now we'll save the rest for
the the patreon maximal episode but I'm
just gonna read a few of my favorite
things I was going through the house
this morning while back was asleep I was
sort of tiptoeing around it sort of
recreating the game that we usually play
with Ella in my own head what are your
favorite things and then more important
than more important part about that game
is why are they your favorite thing
right because we start thinking about
these things in terms of attachment I
realized for me that
a lot of these are my favorite things
just because they'd be inconvenient to
replace that's what I kind of what I
mean by favorite thing I don't really
have a real attachment to them yeah but
for example my bed is number one on my
list favorite things yeah I had no idea
this morning or until this morning what
the brand was I know I've said that a
bunch on this podcast but here's the
thing I'll say the brand is Beautyrest
recharge ultra collection okay I never
heard of it Catherina extra firm oh
sorry to interrupt you in the middle of
you and maybe the brain of your bed but
here's the day I bought it
Denver mattress and in Missoula and it
was I literally walked in there I said
what's the firmest mattress you have and
they showed me this one mattress and
they're like hey I think we have one
that's firmer than that and I tried all
of them out I laid there 15 minutes yeah
this was the firmest but they had and it
is my favorite bed but Beck's isn't a
huge fan of it it's a little bit too
firm for her so keep in mind when we
talk about our favorite things these
aren't things that I'm recommending to
anyone right now they just work for you
they may not be in fact it might be the
opposite of your favorite things they
might just get in the way for you yeah
but that is that is the thing that be
hardest for me to replace where I it
affects my everyday life because if you
don't get a good night's sleep then of
course it affects your podcast your work
or your creativity or whatever we're
doing the next everything for me was my
pillow which goes right and hand-in-hand
with the bed yeah again didn't know the
brand of this either it's called bed
gear balance 3.0 okay I also just look
for a better pillow I got like one
that's too firm and the one that's too
soft this one's pretty firm and it's
also really thick I know Beck's has
tried it a few times she had the balance
2.0 I got it for her which is a little
bit thinner than the one I have and she
like will wake up with like nerve pain
in her arm and like her neck was like
stiff so this didn't work for her either
and I think it's a perfect point even
people who have really similar tastes
you can have slightly different
preferences yeah and my two favorite
things in the house are things that
Beck's doesn't enjoy
at all yeah the third thing for me and
some of the backs is trying to enjoy
pull-up bar oh yeah yeah and I think the
brand I use we'll put a link to these in
the show notes if you could Shawn I
think the brand I use is perfect pull-up
but they make a bunch of different ones
and some of those are actually not that
good so I'll put a link to the actual
one that I use it you've used it before
because it drills right into the
doorframe there it's 20 bucks I think
it's probably the best 20 bucks I've
ever spent because I was just doing
pull-ups this morning and every time I
go to the bathroom I go do some pull-ups
and for folks who are our patreon
supporters they saw me do 239 pull-ups
on Jordans video thanks to his editing
skills yeah I'm glad we're having this
combo man because when when people think
of minimalism they think that like we
don't have anything and like the goal is
to have as little as possible and get by
with as little as possible I mean I even
remember when I first started this whole
experiment man like I wasn't using why
still use my dishwasher but I still wash
my clothes like in a you know in a
washing machine and I use a dryer but
yeah it's it's nice that we can kind of
talk about owning things so we can I
don't know I guess stave off that that
stereotype that minimalists aren't
interested in things at all I mean we
got to consume some stuff to live right
and maybe maybe the better way to look
at that for me now that you say that is
I'm not interested in having attachment
to things so even these favorite things
I'm actually even more interested in in
forming a a slight detachment from these
holding them loosely because I don't
want to hold them too precious when I
start to put them on a pedestal that's
what I worry about when we talk about
favorite things yeah I'm putting on a
pedestal my fourth thing on this list
are my boots
they're from Timberland and I've had
them resold a few times in fact I think
they're on their last leg at this point
yeah and but I've worn the same type of
boots for about eight nine years now and
every time I've tried something else I
like I always go back I walk a ton in
these you know six eight nine ten miles
a day sometimes and they're the most
comfortable shoes I have ever owned the
other day I got the same pair yeah yeah
and yeah they just they work really well
so my first two things were Mariah and
our cat does that not count as favorite
things no they don't
cheese better not be third all right I
guess I won't tell you my top three
favorite things then on this list yeah
man the boots are great
I'd like my Xero shoes but people often
think you're barefoot yeah they actually
think you don't have shoes so you
brought up your bed in your pillow our
bed is probably my favorite thing
announced I didn't put it on my list
because I was just kind of like jotting
stuff down right I'm like yeah totally I
totally agree with you the bed well the
thing is is like my bed is worth more
than my it's a tempur-pedic it's worth
more than my car
but I spend more time on my bed than
anywhere else really yeah so I mean it's
you know kind of feel good about putting
resources there instead of you know with
a nicer newer car or something it would
be really weird if we did advertisements
on this podcast and be like and my
favorite bed is a Casper mattress you
know whatever and it shows up in a tiny
box and right you're like no I I
actually get value out of this am I my
bed is was one of the cheapest beds they
had in the whole store that wasn't
intentional what was intentional for me
like I would have paid twice as much for
the bed I have because it is so
functional for me I want concrete bed to
lay on I'll do two more things about the
pants I have permission workshop which
I'm wearing now and I wear them every
day
in fact I bought a second pair of these
mission workshop hands for the longest
time I just had one pair of pants and
the reason I had a second pair was I had
to get the other pair of repaired
I had like a zipper that I finally broke
because I wear them every day and I need
to get him him'd
and I had a hole in the pocket because I
was wearing them every day and so I have
two pairs of mission workshop pants and
they are by far my favorite pants but I
know this particular size not size
obviously my size wouldn't fit you but
because you all the musculature and your
grease goddess body I have the same
exact pants as you except I got like the
wide leg yeah you got the the gene yeah
they are really awesome pants and
they're like they're durable they're
like I could do karate kicks on them I
do karate all the time and I'm actually
bought them so he can learn karate you
know it's funny that these
Lululemon sweatpants so that I got on
right now these are by far my favorite
out of all the pants I have and like I
literally wear these every single day
like there are places I go coffee shop
grocery store like different places
where people are like man it's always
good to see you and you're always
wearing the same thing yeah sure I am
and well the thing is the thing I enjoy
about these is I have this if you're
watching this on camera can you see this
if I'm moving my cup oh my god what are
you doing this put your pants on there's
a there's a zipper there's a phone
pocket in the cell phone pocket yeah and
means I'm not keeping my phone by my way
can you hear me Sean
I'm not keeping my phone by my testicles
and which is important to me yeah and
yeah I actually took one thing off my
list and I'm upset about this there's
just a lot of speculation about
Bluetooth and potential cancer recently
yeah they're still on my list
yeah air pod the cancer pod that's what
I'm calling about
sea pods and so they are definitely in
my top 5 favorite things if they are not
cancerous yeah but I you know what I
don't know and I'm not I'm not in some
sort of panic about it
mm-hmm but I can save them sorry send me
with the phone next to the nuts exactly
right yeah last but not least and then
we'll go into some questions here we'll
save the rest of this list also I have a
list right of my 15 least favorite
things in my house why do you want a
bird things we're gonna get into that
unless effects
here's here's mr. Bexon there's a hint
there are actually three things that are
on both lists oh my god how could you
say that's a favorite thing and a least
favorite thing but last but not least
for the point of this conversation the
sixth thing on my list is my whole
coffee setup so including yeah the
Bandit coffee that I've been drinking
that I've really been enjoying the Kenya
recently but the whole coffee setup so
yeah the coffee gets on my list too in
this well dude it's like the ritual of
it man right the grinding the pour over
the I don't wants to filter any more but
when I used to have filters that I had
to rinse it's like just even like rinse
it I don't know what it was about like
that fresh clean rinse poster man like
it gets me like this
awesome feeling I don't even know what
is yeah what the so the three things I
have is the encore grinder I think you
might have the same grinder the Bonavita
kettle yep does that get that on my list
and AHA Rio
coffee wait or the the way to say oh yes
Gayle yeah yeah all those are yeah I got
all those three well no yeah I did get
all three of those things a blue bottle
yeah and so all three of those things
although I'm less tied to those
particular brands those are ones that
work really well for me I haven't tried
different brands honestly I've tried a
few different things in the past and
I've I know that these are the best that
I've ever used this it's almost like we
have a little coffee shop in our house
I'll put a link to those in the show
notes because they're there like in
terms of expense they're like
middling level and then two minutes here
they're not really expensive but they're
not cheap either don't have it it's
probably the most expensive thing on
there and they work they work really
well yeah although I'll tell you the
Hori oh scale does not work well if you
get it wet I had to replace it once yeah
that uh that scale glitches out of me
every once in a while dude it's really
weird like my because you're getting it
wet maybe like I'll be pouring coffee in
there and then all sudden it just like
resets on its own anyway we've got a
question here from Nathan in New Orleans
New Orleans you saying it wrong Josh I
have a collection of silver coins and
I've collected them for a while now each
coin is exactly the same this other ones
are all silver eagle coin and I use them
kind of like other people would use in
library once a week gotta look at them
examine them I kind of like that like
Scrooge McDuck I just kill a lot of joy
I was just looking at them which would
be fine if I choose it like a library
but the problem is I never know when to
stop how many should I collect until I
stop like do I stop at ten that's not a
20 dress not that 50 I don't really know
the exact number because they do give me
continuing joy and I do really enjoy
them I'm showing on to my friends when
they hadn't seen them before
but just knowing where it stopped is
something that's very hard for me and
also for like emergency supplies like I
feel a little safer if I have like
some urgency food or emergency water
because you know there are hurricanes
here but where do I draw the line how
much should I collect how much should I
store for emergencies how much how many
of these coins track collections they're
all the same
this is the perfect illustration of
favorite things some of his favorite
things are coin collection yeah a coin
collection for me and I assume for you
would probably be a burden right and so
the thing that he's talking about right
now he has some very specific questions
what's the appropriate number well
kerning according to Marie Kondo it's 30
really she talks about having 30 books
or whatever she really does have a
number on with the appropriate number
though
right which you know you and I we did a
patreon only episode we did the life
tidying magic of gentrification and we
talked about tidying up and
gentrification on one very long episode
and the thing that I worry about is when
we started to treat anything as if it's
too precious so the word that she talks
about is cherish I'm a big fan of what
she's doing to help people tidy up and
take the things that they have in their
life and be more intentional realize
there's so much stuff in the way and I
think her book more so than the than her
TV show I think they both helped with
the Hal to her book also helps a bit
with the y - side of things and better
understanding the things that bring us
joy Nathan your coins bring you joy you
said you were like Scrooge McDuck the
exact sort of swimming in the coins
metaphor I really want to see the
ducktales song I can't for copyright
reasons
[Laughter]
happy birthday think that's why at
restaurants they sing happy birthday
happy happy birthday because they're
he's a jolly good fellow cuz yeah Warner
Brothers has a copyright on yeah I but I
hear that it may be lapsed at some point
yeah you're allowed to say I put now
there they're stuck in the loop anyway
all the coins are exactly the same Ryan
yeah and if that's great it's great if
that's what you want even have a
collection the question then is why
what's the appropriate amount is what
he's asking and I would just turn that
question back around say what is the
appropriate amount for you what
maximizes your joy because if you have
30 coins
will you get twice as much joy from 60
coins if not then we know the answer is
somewhere between 30 and 60 yeah and and
although if you get twice as much joy
from 60 then you're like okay well then
do I get twice as much joy from 120 yeah
and it's so great then maybe the answer
is 120 but what is the number when to
stop you stop when it becomes
inappropriate when there are diminishing
returns Ryan what are your thoughts yeah
no I think that this the answer to this
question is gonna be different for
everyone
I wrote down some questions that Nathan
should ask himself what can you afford
Nathan as far as money time space
attention your going to take care of
those coins I mean you know ask yourself
what you can afford when it comes to
these coins you certainly don't want to
go into debt to get these coins
what are you collecting for I mean just
ask yourself like what is it is it your
collecting because it truly brings you
joy or is it you know sometimes you can
get trapped in the the OCD yeah the
compulsion yes you know Eve yeah the
compulsion of the great work and I'm not
even suggesting that he's doing that but
it's a good question askers ask yourself
Nathan ask yourself is your collection
preventing you from living a meaningful
life if the answer to that is yes it is
preventing you from living a meaningful
life then there's a problem it means
either get rid of the collection or slim
it down till it doesn't prevent you from
living a meaningful life yeah ask
yourself what would my life look like
without the collection so if you know
the the will the next question is is
what if it spontaneously combusted so
let's say you know you're gone and all
of a sudden your coins are gone someone
came in and stole them or they you know
you lost them in a fire like how would
you feel I so that my favorite thing
unless I feel inconvenienced by
realizing all of these right yeah it's
it's yeah yeah and that's oh yeah what
yeah I was going with it's gonna be
it's dangerous to cherish something so
much like that because if you cherish
something to the point where you had
it's gonna devastate you I don't know me
personally I don't think that's a
healthy relationship with things right
yeah
but you know regardless you got to set a
limit for yourself Nathan in that
I understand you're looking for Josh
trying to give you a number but that's a
number that you're gonna have to come up
with yourself yeah and this is kind of
the hardest one of the hardest parts
about living a simple life is you have
to make rules for yourself and you do
have to make choices and that number
might change over time yeah 30 coins
might be appropriate right now but five
years from now maybe it's 20 coins yeah
or maybe it's zero coins no or maybe
it's doubled in 60 coins right but yeah
ask yourself this important questions
Nathan I think that will help guide you
you know the truth is though Josh like
there isn't whether he picks 25 or
whether he picks 200 like that number
doesn't matter
I mean it's he's you know there's a
there's a wide range from 25 to is what
I'll give you Nathan between 25 and 200
coins unless you want more yeah all
right Nathan I'm gonna send you a copy
of our book essential if you like our
podcast you like the audiobook version
if it's our longest audiobook I think
it's like 6 plus hours long but there's
an entire chapter in there about stuff
there's 12 chapters 12 different areas
of intentional living but it's 150
different essays about what it means to
live intentionally through the lens of
these 12 different areas and one of
those areas is about our stuff and coins
are perfect metaphor here Ryan for you
know just everyone's stuff because we
can enjoy them but they may not add
value to someone else's life dude we
totally skipped over his question about
emergencies that's okay we're running
out of time okay well what I'll tell you
with emergencies is is ask yourself what
you're planning for and you know
prepared just for when not not just in
case let's put a link to our just in
case essay and also our just for win
essay we'd like to delineate the to
prepare for just for when not just in
case Ryan with time is it you know what
time it is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we are at
the minimalists on Facebook Twitter
Instagram I learn enlighten around so
Ryan and I each do our best to answer
every question but there's a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of our pithy answers all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place
minimal Maxim's com
all right our first question is from
Ashley how do you part with things that
were once a favorite but you've had a
change of heart about it
my pithy answer is this we must let go
of everything eventually so what things
would you like to weigh you down in the
meantime mmm that's a demon no it's good
I wasn't being facetious man well I I
think because well because it's an
important question it's like what what
are you gonna choose to weigh you down I
might what are the things because the
even the things I get value from they do
have some sort of cost associated with
them like literal like price tag costs
but then the weight of the physical
weight of them the space they take up
the space they take up in my mind to the
mental weight the psychological weight
of these things man it's all gonna weigh
you down so pick only the things you
want to weigh you down yeah I mean when
you look at it that way I mean I you
you're just you're positing it in a way
that's instead of looking at I mean like
Oh what could be my next favorite thing
I mean you're looking at it in the
actual in its actual light of what am I
gonna choose to weigh me down yeah all
right our next question or our next
question I'll read after my pithy answer
my answer is this when we lose a
favorite thing it's not long before a
new thing takes its place so I mean
that's why I'm not really tied to any of
my things or why I cherish any money
even my grandmother's Stein that's
probably like the one thing I have in my
house that every time I walk by like am
i man love love my OMA and I'm really
glad she got me this Stein and I keep
all my loose change in there and you
know it's totally functional but man
like if I if I'd lost that Stein like
then there'd be something else I'm sure
that would replace it a trigger those
memories for you the thing about the
Stein is like that one adds value to
your life but if you would have got you
six of them you'd have five that are in
the way right the last time I was in
Okeechobee Florida I was telling her how
much I liked that sign and she's got on
top of her TV entertainment center Lake
I don't know it doesn't sign she's like
take any of those that you want and I'm
like no I have one I really like it if I
if I get more of them I'm just gonna
dilute them alright our next question is
from Ashley again she has two
questions apparent Thank You Ashley if
we got a bunch of other questions we'll
answer during the the Maxwell opposite
thanks for your questions Ashley her
second question is what do you do about
favorite things that don't seem to add
value just distraction see this question
kind of confused me because I only
distract myself with things that I find
valuable right like I was not true for
me some of the things on my least
favorite list that we'll talk about
later is there are things that are tools
for distraction yeah I mean I'm thinking
like like email I guess is something
that I could use to distract myself but
even then like I find value in
communicating whether it's with someone
you know pitching me hey we got this
podcast platform advertising company if
you're interested in like just giving
them the time of day like you know hey
thanks for reaching out but we don't
advertise or whatever like even that
like I find that communication valuable
in the sense that like someone's asking
for my attention so I give it to them a
little bit sure well my pithy answer is
even our favorite distractions are
distracting and what I'm trying to say
there is that sometimes we distract
ourselves from doing more meaningful
work what Cal Newport would call deep
work yeah right and and because we the
water flows where it's easiest to go do
not tweet that pond and and so we it's
hard for us to do things that that
require what Steven Pressfield will call
the resistance right we have to push
through the resistance to do something
meaningful this is when I'm constantly
distracting myself with something I know
that I'm probably not living my most
meaningful life yeah my pithy answer is
this being productive 24/7 is a
distraction in itself and really what
I'm trying to say here is this too many
distractions it results in an
unfulfilled life and no distractions
also results in an unfulfilled life I
mean we have to find that balance
between leisure and productivity but you
know getting down on ourselves because
you know we're not we're not getting
things done I mean that's that's a
that's a battle you're always going to
lose because you're always going to be
able to do an extra thing or think feel
like you missed out on on an extra thing
to be productive so what are the
approach
distractions and maybe schedule them in
there as well is something that's that's
been helpful for me so I don't fall down
the rabbit hole of distraction
looks like we have several more surprise
questions this week what's one thing you
couldn't live without what are the
minimalist favorite cell phone apps what
are three things you regret getting rid
of I have a good answer for that one how
do you determine whether something adds
value to your life and also I have a
list of my 33 favorite things my 15
least favorite things and three things
that happen to make it onto both lists
and I'll explain why I was actually
confused by this I have some things that
are simultaneously my favorite and least
favorite things
enigma all right you want to hear all
that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon and the second we'll get to are
right here right now segment also our
added value segment but in the meantime
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
we record an entirely different
long-form maximal episode over on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about the topics we don't typically talk
about in public Plus patreon is the best
way for us to fund this podcast and keep
it 100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than 100 private
podcast episodes you can find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional private podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists
dot-com slash support Ryan what else you
got for us this week you know being
informed is the most important thing to
really I don't know have having our
brains these days man it's like we get
bombarded with so much information and
so many memes sometimes the information
we mistake we mistake memes for factual
information that's trivia mistake
information with being informed you can
read a tabloid magazine and get
information but not be informed about
the world around you
yes so y'all got to get out there read
more stay informed make your own
decisions and also here I got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check moe
hi my name is Hannah and I'm from LA and
I wanted to leave a comment for
listeners based on your addiction
episode my husband and I have been
dealing with addiction issues and our
families in relationship for many years
and we've finally found an approach that
has aligned well with minimalism and all
the things we've learned from Josh and
Ryan so there's a recovery program
called smart recovery for addicts and
loved ones as well as a book for loved
ones called Beyond addiction how science
and kindness can help people change
both encourage a real methodology
steeped in science that allowed us to
simplify these really intimidating
issues we wanted to share what we found
in hopes that it will help other
minimalist simplify the complexity of
addiction issues in their life hi my
name is Amanda from revelstoke b.c
Canada and these tips are for a Jeremy
from episode 1 for 7 regarding his
questions concerning saving for his
child's future educational costs with an
ex-partner as a divorced mom myself with
an ex-partner who didn't initially see
the value in saving for our son's future
education I would recommend the
following number one if possible try to
have something added to your separation
agreement which states exactly how much
each parent is to contribute annually to
an education savings fund for your child
number 2 get creative start chatting
with your child now about different ways
to save money and work while in
university to make up for any shortfalls
for example things like becoming a paid
teachers assistant resident advisor
Campus Bookstore rep etc you can also
start talking to them about finding jobs
that will pay for their living expenses
plus a little bit extra during their
university breaks things like summer
camps resorts and cruise ships are all
great options in this way students can
work during all of their breaks not live
at home during their breaks see the
world and get paid to do it
in fact I personally was able to work
seasonally during my entire 6 years of
Univ
Cristi where i earned four degrees and
pay off thirty-five thousand dollars in
student loan debt in just one year of
working full-time on cruise ships after
I finished my last degree a great place
to start your research is YouTube for
example you can just YouTube or Google
how to work on a cruise ship seasonally
and you'll come across just a ton of
info I want everyone to know there are
ways to finishing University almost
completely debt-free or debt free
totally get paid to travel and see the
world and build your resume at the same
time I hope this info helps and thanks
guys for everything you do all right
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist I talked about
the coffee that we have Ryan our coffee
shop is called banded coffee and down in
st. Petersburg Florida yell of course
you can check that out we're adding a
restaurant component to that really soon
as well but if you're not in Florida and
you want to try some of our coffee it's
finally available online if you've got a
bandit Coffee Co it's bandit coffee
that's co and then I think by the time
this episode comes out we should have
the minimalists choice so we're doing a
different choice every month like we're
Ryan and I we we try out all the
different coffees that we're roasting
down in Florida we only talk about
preferences and things like this is our
favorite coffee but it may not be your
you know it's funny is like the the my
aunt like I was talking her I sent her
some coffee she's like Ryan that coffee
is like it's doesn't have that like you
know really strong coffee flavor and
it's kind of tea like and you know I
really like my you know I don't know
Peruvian dark roast blah blah blah blah
and I'm like yeah you're right like then
our coffee wouldn't be for you and like
it's we have a lighter roast it's more
you know like a delicate tea like rather
than like that robust even saying robust
is like yeah it's a weird noxious
meaningless buzzword yeah yeah yeah and
so we we tend the roast three to seven
different coffees at a time from
different regions source all of the
beans ourselves weaver just got back
from Mexico recently and has been all
over the world finding the beans that we
can source and source continually and so
they've done a really good job of
curating and roasting we've been
roasting for a couple years now we're
finally ready to
let the public know about it and let you
try it out so bandit coffee dot Co if
you want to try some coffee let us know
if it adds value to your life you can
you can always message us on Twitter or
whatever social media platform that you
use if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave a
voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or send
a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists you can also see my weird
phone pocket over there if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at the minimalists comm and
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for our added value
segment this week this is a song you
mentioned to me on Monday Ryan we were
being so LA on Monday Jordan was taking
photos of us on La Cienega Boulevard man
and you're like hey man you check out
the the new Khaleed album and he's like
dropping one song at a time and it's a
song on there called better yeah and I
like the song because it sounds what it
feels like to fall in love again yeah I
hear the song I think of Beck's every
time that I listen to it it's like
upbeat and and falling in love all over
again yeah it's a great song so you like
you all can check that out and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus